Air Forces from across NATO are taking
part in the alliance's annual nuclear
exercise the drills involve 14 countries
and up to 60 aircraft they'll conduct
training flights over Belgium as well as
the North Sea and the UK meanwhile
Russia is holding its own annual nuclear
drills which usually take place in late
October Natasha Butler has more from
Paris
at a NATO defense ministers meeting in
Brussels Yen stoltenberg those said that
NATO would certainly not cancel these
exercises this year and in fact it would
not be a good thing to do so it would
send the wrong message he said to Moscow
at this particularly difficult time when
Russia has been stepping up its rhetoric
when it comes to threats about using
nuclear weapons we've heard a lot from
Moscow about that we know that the NATO
alliance says that it's taking those
threats very seriously indeed it is
watching them closely at this point the
alliance says that it really feels those
threats are more about trying to deter
Western powers from taking part in this
conflict but nevertheless as I said
being looked at very seriously in fact
the U.S defense secretary Lloyd Austin
said any Nuclear Strike by Russia would
receive a response from Ukraine's allies
he didn't exactly say what it would be
he said it would be a physical response
we then heard a little bit later from
the French President Emmanuel macro
seemed to almost contradict that
Emmanuel mackerel saying that uh that
allies would not use a nuclear weapon
against any Nuclear Strike by Russia but
he wasn't totally clear about exactly
what would happen uh nevertheless it's
important to note that France is not
part of operation steadfast noon it's
not part of these exercises uh even
though France is one of the only three
uh nuclear powers in The Alliance along
with the US and the UK but France is not
part of NATO's nuclear deterrent
Planning Group
Elizabeth brow is a senior fellow at the
American Enterprise Institute she joins
us live now from Washington DC to talk
more about this thanks very much for
being with us
um now as we were saying these are uh
annual uh drills that uh that NATO and
and the Russians are regularly conduct
but of course they've taken on
um much greater significance with the
war in Ukraine and that's part of the
reason uh we're talking to you just just
talk us through what we should be
looking for here
yes as you say these exercises take
place every year and and unsurprisingly
so because if you've got nuclear weapons
you've got to exercise how you would be
using them uh otherwise you will lose
those skills but obviously what what has
changed in the past six months or so is
Russia's signaling uh or the signaling
by by some Russian officials that Russia
may be willing to use or prepare to use
nuclear weapons against Ukraine and so
uh these exercises that we which you
usually take place without much public
uh interest at all are now suddenly
extremely interesting and and they are
interesting not just for for NATO to
watch what the Russians are doing and
and vice versa but also for the general
public in Ukraine and indeed for all of
us because if a nuclear weapon is used
somewhere
uh it it clearly uh would uh mean risk
escalation that would involve all of us
but we should also remember that that
exercises are merely that it doesn't
mean that that these uh either side is
more or less willing to use in nuclear
weapon but it does come against the
background of Russia being willing to
use nuclear weapons and is there any
significance in these exercises taking
place at the same time
there really isn't it's these sorts of
things uh all military exercises are
scheduled long in advance but I think
what what is really uh crucial to be
watching it this year is what what the
Russians do now they are not very
transparent about their military
exercises ever uh so it's it's not very
easy to discern what exactly they they
practice but I think what we should all
be trying to to get some sort of clarity
about is what sort of nuclear weapons
they are involving in this exercise and
that comes against the background of
Russia having developed the so-called
low-yield nuclear warhead over the past
few years so what what some people would
call a mini nuke that is less powerful
than traditional nuclear weapons that
have been used or have been developed in
the past and and so uh what is really
important to establish is how Russia
might think about this in this weapon
and how mad use it and of course that is
what do you trainers are worried about
that the Russians will use a small
nuclear weapon there and then what
happens but and that's why it's so
important to watch this exercise to see
exactly uh or see at least with some
sort of
um Clarity but what the Russians may
have in mind even though they don't say
or show very much what are the
implications uh of this beyond the
immediate conflict in Ukraine to the
rest of the world
well so there are two implications one
is that that a nuclear war which was
such a a an unlikely scenario for so
many years indeed for more than three
decades all of a sudden that is
something that is
um that is not totally unlikely anymore
and that is a radical change really uh
from the year the from the from the
lives we have been living now for for
three decades and the other thing is
that
um and this sounds like a very technical
thing but
um insurance policies uh for industry
all over the world including Aviation uh
have only
thought about one or that there is only
one kind of nuclear conflict mentioned
in those new insurance policies and that
is uh sort of a global nuclear conflict
and if one that means that if one
nuclear weapon is used against Ukraine
uh that that means that insurance
policies on null and void for the most
part so for example uh Global Aviation
would be halted that's something to bear
in mind it doesn't mean that that Russia
will use these exercises for something
like that but it does mean that we we
have to pay really close attention to
what they may have in mind because it is
something that will affect not just the
people who might be affected in Ukraine
but the whole way globalization is set
up
good to get your analysis Elizabeth
Brown in Washington thanks for being
with us